презентація дуб та вигляді намахалися easier
вати алли виступ у Москві так і вид гусака
показав ще кадиров ще до презентації ви
call of duty адже вусів міражах назвав
та й не чим у крем бала конини
uuid по відео ш написавши через готовий
оксана голова чечні все про прилюдно на
моїй сунні viva жах публіці додати
прочитають у неї яшина разів коли я про на
зливки цей гай путін дав кадирову
повну свободу піруват очищеним в обмін
на душі не сепаратистських настроїв
це окрема незалежність криму
затримала близько 3 малюків з них гаю
створить владну армію, то по суті давно
вже дістав звідкись з російською
законам ще раз федеральна влада того
щоб такий путін закриває ночі
причому у яких ський режим настеньке
агресивний і нас тількін і коровані
судді чечні йому віри видно будуть за малу
і ти масаж краще зачепа протезе і
кадирова на сусіди території для яшин
обожнюю кадиров і так дзвони кадиров типів
я за не дарма цьому політичному в
вам і в росії засіків швидкому
опозиційні роботи з одним словом на
ще давно в інстаграмі Кадирова було
опубліковано відео на та кому знято
опозиційних політиків
володаря караму розуму кращого і
Михайла Касянова з пивасом хто не відразу
міф тобто у розумі та торік ми
на лузі руку в побуті бориса німцова так
вже реакції вид початку не було а буш був
аякасі неадекватно готові ображаю
граматики з фактичного поставила в
море і влади в результаті путін став
обумовлюватися в цій приємності
висловлюватися про неприйнятність
а через скільки днів вписав був
німцова путін городи в кадирова органом
по шан і за балад і річкову сулін
втратив потурання як від рівня
кадирову зате віл вони всіх його
досвід і тиф і фінансових та політичних
демонстрацій кремль знаходиться в абсолют
нерозумності розуміється путін вирости
в монс цього монстра владимир путін
захищай кадирова в кілька років
за три години глава чечні закріпивши за
собою imagine зраду були дірка
чеченського народу виріс не 2016 руку в
чечне відбудуться вибори глави республіки
протез супер нікі-віки реально
претендує на тип саду у кодованому а
я